- It's so fun.
You get so drunk.
You start a bonfire outside.
You fucking firebomb anybody
that tries
to get through the gates.
A lot of times it's your
cousin, you know.
You don't even care.
[dark electronic music]
[bell dinging]
Oh.
[chuckles]
Nicely done.
Yes.
Mmm.
Mmm!
[moaning]
[piglet whining]
♪ ♪
[fork clatters]
[whining]
♪ ♪
[whining continues]
Your mama's so delicious.
[cheers and applause]
- This next man just finished
his 130th movie.
Tom Arnold, everybody!
[cheers and applause]
- I'm gonna tell you about some
jobs I had.
I had a great job.
I worked at a meat-packing
plant for three years.
Anybody else done that?
The Hormel meat-packing plant
in Ottumwa, Iowa.
By the way, if you work on the
kill floor
of a meat-packing plant, you
will get very drunk every day.
Okay?
There's a documentary called
"American Dream"--
It won an academy award in
1990--
about our meat-packing plant.
I voted for every strike that
came up.
I didn't even read the
paperwork, you know,
and by the way, man, it's so
fun.
You get so drunk.
You start a bonfire outside.
You fucking firebomb anybody
that tries
to get through the gates.
A lot of times it's your
cousin, you know.
You don't even care.
And then people were
interviewing us outside,
and they're like, "Why are you
striking?"
And I go, "I have no idea, but
it's fucking fun, man.
I know that."
And if you watch that
documentary,
you see what happens.
The company just fired us and
just changed the name of the
business, and then they hired
people from other countries
to work for half the pay.
Yeah, anyway, it didn't work
out too well,
but my best job, I think, was
McDonald's.
So after that, I went to the
University of Iowa,
and I needed money, right?
So--first I applied at Pizza
Hut.
But they made you take a lie
detector, so...
and then they ask you
questions, you know,
real personal ones, like, "Have
you ever stolen food,"
and earlier in my life, I
worked on a farm.
I grew up on farms, and I was
bailing hay for a guy.
We all did--for 14 hours--
and this guy was supposed
to pay us $1.40 an hour, and
he was an asshole,
and he only gave us 70 cents an
hour,
'cause he said we drank too
much water.
So I sold one of his cows.
Anyway, that's technically
stealing.
I think it's technically--
I did, for real.
I don't consider it stealing,
but anyway,
so--and I had, like, a fucking
Pinto.
It was a tough--anyway, but I
had those bungee cords.
I mean, he was safe.
Anyway, it's a long story...
That's true.
So, I get this job
at McDonald's in Iowa City.
And it is the best job because,
if you unload the truck
on Thursdays,
you get one meal
of whatever you want to eat.
So I would have eight Big Macs
with Quarter-Pounder meat
and a Diet Coke.
And then
I would start my workday,
you know, feeling totally
sick and disgusting.
And that's--it's shocking
I became a drug addict
because of that.
Anyway, but I loved there.
I got to play Ronald McDonald
for the kids on Sundays
with terrible hangovers.
It was just
a wonderful place to work.
And all my friends loved it.
You know how
your friends love it
when you work at a place
like that, right?
They fucking line up there.
And they want free food.
You know?
And it's really hard
'cause they got computers,
so you gotta pay attention
and keep track of the food.
And you have to pretend
you've thrown food
into the hopper that
was in there too long,
and you've thrown it away,
so when you're giving away
free food.
And, you know--and by the way,
all that food
that was in the hopper
that they put into
a trash thing,
I take home every night.
And my roommates, we love it.
And sometimes
we'd get a bad Filet-O-Fish
or something
and somebody gets really sick.
But anyway--
otherwise it's a waste.
It's only been in there
12 hours, that's fine.
So...
[light laughter, murmuring]
And anyway...
So, my buddy, Moe,
who's still my buddy,
you know, he comes in there
every Friday,
and he wants
a bag of cheeseburgers.
So I give him
I give all my friends whatever.
And then I have to figure out
on the computer--
you know, 'cause it makes you
real smart working there.
And...and then I see Moe.
He's talking to the owner,
Kevin [bleep].
And they're pointing at me.
And I'm like, what's going on?
And he goes,
"This customer says
you forgot some
of his cheeseburgers."
Like, my own fucking buddy
is narcing on me,
who I just gave free--
you know, that's the kind
of friends I have, so...
I also had a part-time job at
Paul's Discount,
and this really helped.
And what I did to Paul's
Discount was,
every day I'd go into work, and
then I'd get a gym bag
off the shelf, and I'd fill it
up with stuff
that friends wanted me to
steal,
and I'd go home with a full gym
bag,
and the owner would take me
home.
And every night, it was scary,
'cause it still had
the things on it, and, you
know, the clips.
And I just prayed he'd shut off
the security system
as I walked by the cash
registers.
And so it was a very exciting
place to work.
And then--and then one day a
beer distributor came in
and said he wanted some golf
clubs and stuff,
and I said, "I'll make you a
deal.
"You drop off 50 cases of beer
at my house,
and I'll make this trade," so
we--you know,
a good deal for everybody.
And--and it was a Friday night,
Iowa football game,
so I knew we were gonna be
partying very hard,
and also, McDonald's,
we had this game going.
And every time
you bought a bag of food,
we put a game ticket in,
and you could win a Big Mac
or a Big Breakfast or $5.
And so, I was getting ready
to leave--it was Friday night.
And I see a box of those,
6,000.
And I'm like, fuck that.
I'm taking it home.
So I take home the box,
and me and my friends
stayed up all night.
Our fingernails were--
were just destroyed,
'cause you gotta rip
the sides off.
And in the morning, we had
157 free Big Breakfastes.
And we'd been up all night with
the free beer.
And it was, like, a real classy
party,
like, you know, a brunch of
something,
so, anyway,
we go down to McDonald's.
Since I work there,
I can't cash it in.
But my buddy Moe can.
So I park behind the dumpster.
And Moe goes in
and he goes up to the front.
And he puts them up there
and he says,
"I'd like
157 free Big Breakfastes."
And the lady goes,
"Oh, I'm sorry, sir, did
you not read the fine print?
It's only one per visit."
And my friend Moe
is pretty smart.
He's like,
"Boy, the kids at the home
are gonna be pretty sad."
And Kevin [bleep], the owner,
who's still the owner,
runs over and goes,
"Sir, we will honor those.
For the kids."
So the next thing I see
is my buddy Moe
with a giant cardboard box
full of Big Breakfastes.
I'm like, holy shit, we did it.
We did it.
Brilliant.
And then right behind him
is Kevin [bleep],
the owner of McDonald's
with another big box
of Big Breakfastes.
And I realize, I'm gonna
be fired in about five seconds.
And Kevin [bleep],
that guy is such a jerk,
he didn't even
take the food back.
He just looked at me in the car
and just gave me that, "I'm...
"I'm so disappointed.
"I considered you assistant
manager material, Tom.
You could've ended up
at Hamburger U."
Anyway, so that's my last day
at McDonald's.
So...later in life...
I know, it's sad.
It was a great job.
Later in life, I got sober,
and when you get sober
you have to make a list
of all the people
you need to make amends to.
And mine was
a pretty extensive list.
And...once I got past
the girlfriends
whose credit I'd ruined,
I got to McDonald's
and Paul's Discount,
and I sent them checks.
And...I called Kevin [bleep].
And he's such a nice guy,
he cried.
And he wouldn't take the money.
He had to give it to
the Ronald McDonald House.
How nice is that, right?
'Cause I'd stolen, you know,
$10,000 worth of food.
I mean, that's pretty--
like, that is...
The one thing I did do,
when I left,
they stopped putting pockets
on the uniforms.
'Cause I--you know.
Anyway...
but there's a happy ending,
because one time
I hosted "Saturday Night Live."
And I got to play a McDonald's
manager,
And this was when Bill Clinton
was president
and would always go to
McDonald's.
And the great Phil Hartman,
who I love too...
Yeah, everybody...
[cheers and applause]
Most of the people that I love
are dead now apparently,
but Phil Hartman was wonderful,
and I had--
I played Kevin [bleep].
I had his name tag on there
as a tribute to that guy,
so that's a happy ending to
that story.
Thank you guys very much
for being here.
Thank you.
- Tom Arnold, y'all.
[cheers and applause]
Yeah.